hello hi it's so good to see you um so
first off the the chemistry between the
two of you in this is incredible uh
Amani I'll start with you did you guys
was it instantaneous or what did you do
to bond you know on set or even before
this to sort of make sure that that was
there yeah it was written in the stars
if it was online far before we met each
other uh before we did our chemistry
read we both were like but like this is
Jules this is Cal we were meant to be
and our first conversation even we were
on FaceTime for like four hours just
getting to know each other and that's
when we realized how similar we truly
are and yeah reading a lot of the same
books and just excited to support one
another through this journey and to
bring these characters to life but Sarah
Catherine is a light and it's she's such
a kindred spirit it's hard not to adore
her so and uh Sarah Catherine normally
with us with a story like this you know
the focus usually is you know a coming
out storage the realization that you're
gay which is which is all great but with
this one it starts off everybody knows
who they are and then it's down to it's
down to business and it's a different
way of telling sort of a youth gay story
yeah absolutely that was something that
we really loved about this story was
that it's as as far as the
representation is concerned this isn't
this isn't the queerness is not a point
of conflict for them it was never
questioned and it's accepted and even
celebrated and we're just so excited for
queer audiences to be able to see
themselves in these characters yeah
there's always been a thing the gay
community has always embraced vampires
vampires have always been sort of you
know uh and ambiguous what is it about
those two cultures that work so well
together in this show like it is it's
perfect
yeah no that's a good observation yeah I
I personally think it's because they're
in communities where maybe they're just
always misunderstood you know and I
think it's a thing of like there's
something about them that makes them who
they are that they can't change and that
they're born into and it's not something
that they can just turn off and um I
think it's important that we accept
those kind of people you know that
they're they're born into who they are
and they're on the right track they were
born this way that's right and that's
just what it is and uh Sarah Catherine
if if you could take another either
vampire or Vampire Slayer from another
world and bring them into the first kill
universe who would that be oh what a
great question I would probably request
the entire cast of what we do in the
shadows
uh movie and TV show to be a part of it
I think it would be a riot and Imani
oh we need some mermaids in there I
don't know I think they're so cool and I
think again they just they they look so
like Majestic and so sweet and all these
things but they can be a little dark and
a little scary and things in the water
like scaring the hell out of me so I
think that could be like awesome and uh
but before I let you go uh uh Emma
Roberts EP on the show did you guys have
a lot of time together uh with her at
all unfortunately not really we didn't
get to she she wasn't able to come to
set um but we as far as bellatris is
concerned we got very close with Kara
price she came to set a lot and she's
part of the bellatrist production
company
um so but I we plan to to hang out with
Emma more in the future that's
incredible thank you so much it was a
pleasure the show's a whole lot of fun
uh you two are both really wonderful
appreciate your time thank you so much